breaking news overnight in israel police
are bracing for more protests and
clashes with palestinians today
after a night of violence in east
jerusalem that left more than 200 people
injured
and it comes after weeks of unrest this
morning the state department called on
both sides to stop
the violence mts tayab is in our london
newsroom with the very latest mtas good
morning
everyone good morning while tensions are
at a fever pitch in east jerusalem after
protests over the possible evictions of
palestinian families from their homes
spilled over into the al-aqsa mosque
complex one of islam's
holiest sites now israeli police can be
seen firing rubber-coated steel bullets
and stun grenades at rock-throwing
palestinians
but it was this moment when worshippers
offering evening prayers
on the last friday of the holy month of
ramadan were caught up in the violence
that has sparked the most
outrage hundreds can be seen fleeing for
safety when
thick plumes of tear gas flooded the
prayer hall
the intense protests have been going on
for weeks now
most of it's centered in the east
jerusalem neighborhood of sheikh jarrah
where a number of palestinian families
are facing evictions from homes
they've lived in since the 1950s by a
group of jewish settlers who claimed the
land
as their own the state department has
said it was deeply concerned about the
situation
and has appealed for calm but calm is
unlikely on monday israel's supreme
court will hold the hearing on the
sheikh jarrah evictions
leaving many in the holy city bracing
themselves for even more violence
michelle not good to hear mts thank you